اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرضون معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
معارك طاحنه
يستهدف جسرا في ضواحي المدينه يخلف قتلى
وجرحى
المرصد يؤكد سقوط سبعه
ميليشيات الايرانيه بمدينه القائم
الحدوديه
ايران تهدد اوكرانيا وتطالبها بتبرئه
نفسها من هجمات اصفهان
ينفي ضلوعه
تقارير تؤكد حصول الصين على على رقائق
امريكيه لمعهد ابحاث اسلحه النوويه رغم
قيود التصدير
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من تطورات
المعارك الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن
السلطات لروسيا سقوط اربعه وخمسه مصابين
بقصف الاوكرانيين على جسر في ضواحي
المدينه كما دورت صف صفارات الانذار التي
تحذر من ضربات جويه في مناطق دنيا اسكوزا
بين القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه في
هذه المناطق في سياق ذاته تقوم كيف بنقل
تعزيزات العسكريه اضافيه الى منطقه التجمع
السكانيه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول بناء تحصينات
جديده وزرعه
النقل هامه لدعم القوه الاوكرانيه
في المقابل المشاهدين قال حيث ان صاروخان
اصابنا سكنيه في مدينه ثاني اكبر المدن
الاوكرانيه ما ادى الى مقتل شخص واصابه
اخرين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من دوني اسف ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر اهلا بك رائد رائد مع
الشداد المعارك في دنياز حيث انت لم يعد
خط المواجهه واضحا بين الفرق المتحاربه
الان كيف يمكن توصيف الموقف الميداني
الروسي تحديدا
نهارك طيب احمد بالفعل المعارك مستعره في
جميع المحاور التي تقف فيها
القوات الروسيه وتتمركز فيها ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه ربما نبدا من مقاطعه التي تشتد
فيها المعارك في المحاور الجنوبيه
والشماليه في جنوب دانيس تقع مدينه
اوغلودار مدينه اوغلادار هي المتاخمه من
الناحيه الشماليه لمدينه زاباروجا التي
اسلفت بان سقطت فيها صواريخ اصابه جسرا
قتل همم اربعه مدنيين وهمم واصابات عديده
اكثر من خمسه اصابات اضافه الى الحديث
يعني مفقودين تحت همم الانقاذ حتى الان
المعارك محتدمه في المحور الجنوبي من
المقاطعه الثانيه حول اوغدار بالفعل دخلت
القوات الروسيه من منطقه جنوب وكما كانوا
يقولون بان عمليات تنظيف من يعني فل الجيش
الاوكراني ما زالت مستمره الحديث اليوم عن
وصول الى البنايات الشاهقه التي يتمركز
فيها الجيش الاوكراني ويضرب تقدم القوات
الروسيه حرب شوارع قتال شوارع في المنطقه
الجنوبيه اليوم اعلن ديميس بوشرن زعيم
الانفصاليين هنا في ثانيه او رئيس
الجمهوريه
المعين من روسيا والمنتخب اعلن ان القوات
الروسيه ايضا اكملت الطوق من الناحيه
الشرقيه وان الناحيه الشرقيه بدات القوات
الروسيه ايضا تدخل لمدينه اوغلودار وتسيطر
على نقاط وتدفع الاجانب الاوكراني
للانسحاب من هذه النقاب ما زالت معارك
ضاريه من اجل السيطره على مدينه جرادار
جنوب
شوارع اذا هناك يعني دخول للقوات الروسيه
الى المدينه
تضارب كبير جدا في الانباء حول
اذا كنت طيبا همم هناك التيار كبير بين
القوات الروسيه او دعنا نقل فاجنر التي
تؤكد انها سيطر على كم المدينه ونفي ايضا
مقابل من القوات الاوكرانيه اين تكمل
الحقيقه رائد
الحقيقه في ان القوه الروسيه بالفعل تسيطر
على المنطقه الشماليه من حول مدينه
باخموتو بلده داتني هي تعتبر خلف سوليدار
سوليدار التي انسحب منها فعلا الجيش
الاوكراني واعلن ذلك هي عباره عن تقدم
للقوات همم خاصه الروسيه او فاجنر كما
اسلفت من الناحيه الشماليه من المنطقه
واعلنت عن سيطرتها على منطقه بلاجاباتني
اذا الجانب الاوكراني رفض او لم يعترف
بهذا الانسحاب فربما يكون ماذا لا متمركز
في جيوب هذه البلده او المدينه وما زال
يقصف تقدم القوات الروسيه لكن اذا اعلنت
القوات الروسيه انها سيطرت على المدينه
فهذا يعني على الاقل بان حرب شوارع قائمه
وهناك تقدم روسي في هذه البلد نعم نعم
هي على تخوم مدينه سيفرت ااا القابعه في
شمال اقصى شمال دنياسك وتعتبر على الطرف
الاخر من الاستشانس حيث تمركز القوات
الروسيه بعد ان دفعت القوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحابيه اخر معاقل الجيش الاوكراني في
تلك المنطقه القريبه على المدن الكبرى
باخمه
هذه التفاصيل
يحدث هذا مشاهدينا في ما تحدثت انباء من
اوكرانيا عن تعويض السلطات على بدء
استخدام الدبابات الغربيه في فصل الربيع
حيث من المحتمل ان تدخل الحرب منعطفا
جديدا يشن يشن من خلالها الى الجانبين
الاوكراني والروسي هجمات كبرى وبحسب وزير
الدفاع الاخرى تعتزم القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه تشكيله كتيبتيه دبابات على
الاقل من هذه الدبابات التي وردت بها
الدول الغربيه والتي ستستخدم لمواصله
الهجوم المضاد حسب قوله واعرب الوزير
عثيقته في ان الدول الغربيه ستواصل تزويدك
في انواع الحديثه من الذباب سياسيه
مشاهدينا اعلنا الامين العام لحزب الناتجه
ان رد على المواسع الامريكي يقوم بدور
كبير لصالح حلفاء واشنطن
على خلفيه تصرفات روسيا والصين وكوريا
الشماليه وسجل اسطنبول على اهميه ردع
النووي في مثل هذه الظروف خاصه مع امتلاك
روسيا والصين وكوريا الشماليه للترسانه
النوويه واضاف ان العالم سيكون في خطر
اكبر اذا تخلى الدول الميتو مثل الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا عن الاسلحه النوويه بدوره
مشاهدينا توسع رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني في
حديثه لصحيفه
انضمام بلاده الاتحاد الاوروبي في وطني
العامين المقبلين واعرب شمال في ان تتمكن
خلال قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي المقرره يوم
الثالث من فبراير من تحقيق تقدم كبير بشان
اتفاق حول مرور السلع الصناعيه وتعليق
الرسوم الجمركيه لمده عام وانضمام
اوكرانيا
التجوال في الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذا في ما اشارت الصحيفه الى ان خطه كييفر
لانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي تمثل مشكله
لان لا احد في الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبرها
واقعيه على حد وصفها كشف صحيفه الجاردن
البريطانيه ان المعركه الكبرى في اوكرانيا
ستبدا في الربيع القادم وتوقعت ان تكون
اشد مراحل حرب ضراوه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
المعركه الكبرى في اوكرانيا ستبدا خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله والسؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه هنا من سيضرب اولا وايت سؤال طرحته
صحيفه الجارديان بريطانيا
في الجنوب الاوكراني الذي يبلغ طوله 1200
كيلو متر ومن المتوقع وفق خبراء عسكريين
تحدثوا الجاردن ان تندلع هناك اشد مراحل
الحرب ضراوه منذ بدايه الحرب وفي انتظار
اطلاق شراره الحرب وشراره المعركه القادمه
روسيا تعمل على تقويه قوتها عبر تحريك
وتوجيه اقتصاد البلاد نحو الصناعه الحربيه
من اجل انتاج طبعا دبابات وصواريخ جديده
وفقا لها هؤلاء الخبراء بعدما مثلت
المرحله الاولى من العمليه العسكريه حرب
استنزاف كبيره للجانب الروسي همم طبعا
للكريم كلفته الاف الجنوب بالاضافه الى
الخسائر التي لحقت بالترسانه الصاروخيه
التي استخدمت فيها وستخدمت بقصف البنيه
التحتيه طاقه باوكرانيا اما الجانب
الاوكراني فيتحضر لاخذ زمام المبادره
والشروع بالهجوم اولا والسباق الهجمات
الروسيه ولكن غياب الاسلحه الثقيله
لاختراق المواقع الروسيه يتسبب لها بحاله
احباط الا اذا كان للدبابات الغربيه التي
استلمتها مؤخرا كلام اخر هناك ثلاث جبهات
يمكن ان تكون ساحه للمعارك الضاريه في
الربيع المقبل ويمكن ان يكون حسم اي واحده
منها ومنعرج نحاسما لهذه الحرب جبهه الشرق
وهنا نتحدث عن لهانسك ودنياسك التي كانت
مسرحا لاشد المعارك في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه وهي طبعا اكثر الاماكن احتماليه
لشنها جمال كبرى من كلا الجانبين في
الربيع المقبل جبهه الجنوب في اتجاه جزيره
القرم طبعا وهي الجبهه الاهم بالنسبه
للطرفين الاكراني والروسيه لانها طبعا
ستقرر نتيجه الحرب برمتها سواء ش القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الهجوم الاول في الشرق
ام لا وتبقى طبعا جبهه الشمال حيث تحشت
روسيا قواتها للتدريب في بيلاروسيا ولكن
يبقى هذا الامر خدعه من قبل موسكو لابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه عن الجنوب والشرق بحسب
الصحيفه
تصب الزيت على النار بشان الصراعي في
اوكرانيا
روسيا والولايات المتحده في تواصلان
محادثاتهم
اضافه انه ليس من المرجح ان ينتهي الامر
بتبادل يشمل جميع السجناء لدى الجانبين
يجتمع وزير الدفاع والخارجيه الفرنسيه
قبل عامين عندما الغت حكومه المحافظين
الاستراليه السابقه فجاه عقدا قيمته نحو
60 مليار دولار لشراء غواصات من مجموعه
نظال حيث فضلت حينها عوضا عن ذلك الحصول
على غواصات بريطانيه وامريكيه تعملوا
بالطاقه النوويه
حضرت وكاله النور نيوز المقربه من مجلس
الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني حذرت
اوكرانيا من تبعات تواطئها المحتمل في
الهجوم الذي استهدف عددا من المواقع
العسكريه في ايران اخيرا التحضير الايراني
جاء بعد تعليق المستشار الاوكراني ميخائيل
البدليك والذي قال فيه ان المنطقه الحربي
لا يرحم ووجهها رساله الى ايران قال فيها
حذرناكم مشيرا الى تغبيره وجه بها رساله
الى ايران في ديسمبر الماضي اتهم فيها
طيران
[موسيقى]
روسيا وجعل للتخلي عن العقوبات الدوريه
غير الفعاله والتركيز على تدمير مصانع
الصواريخ والمسيرات الايرانيه
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان
الطائرات مجهوله استهدف السته شاحنات
تبريد كانت تنقل اسلحه ايرانيه في شرق
سوريا فور دخولها من العراق كما اوضح مصر
السوري انا الاستهداف ادى الى تدمير
الشاحنات ومقتل واصابه بداخلها في ري في
مدينه ابو كمال الحدوديه واكد المصد ان
ضربه الجوي ادت الى مقتل سبعه اشخاص
موالينا لايران وتدمير الشاحنات بالكامل
وقال مدير المرصد رامي عبد الرحمن ان
قافلتين ممثلين افرغته حمولتهما من اسلحه
ايرانيه في مدينه الميادين عقب عبورهما من
الحدود العراقيه خلال الاسبوع الجاري
مشاهدينا من القاهره
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
سيد رامي معنا في هذه النشره قبل الحديث
عن هجوم الامس على الحدود السوريه
العراقيه نتحدث اليوم عن هجوم او قصف قال
ربما
منطقه البوكمال السوريه ماذا نعرف عن ذلك
من قبل الايراني
ولكن ما يهمنا الان بان ما جرى يوم امس هو
همم يتعلق قد يكون اسرائيل وراء الامر وهي
التي تتحدث مثل ما كان عليه الحال في
استهداف قناه الصهاريج عندما نتحدث عن
استهداف في الشاحنات من ضمن اكثر من 20
شاحنات دخلت الاراضي السوريه بان الجهه
التي استضافتها هذه الشهادات تعلم ما هو
داخل هذه الشاحنات ولماذا تم اجر استهداف
هذه الشاحنات بعينها ولماذا حصلت
الانفجارات بهذه الشاحنات التي قيل انه
بانها تحمل ماده الطحين وفقا لاحده
الفضائيات المقربه من ايران العربيه
المقرره لبنان وايضا كان هناك قبل ايام
يعني في الرابع والعشرين دخلت شاحنات او
برادات همم من العراق
باتجاه العراق وكان يقودها عناصر من حزب
الله لبناني
بالصوت والصوره عندما دخل همم عده
السيارات داخل الاراضي السوريه بعد ذلك
تابعه مسيره مسيرته باتجاه دير الزور وخرج
من الديانه الزور
بسياره بشاحنه
ما لكيش دعوه في العاصمه السوريه دمشق لان
هناك تحرك مستمر لايران للشيختها داخل
الاراضي السوريه اما جرى يوم امس قد تكون
اسرائيل وراءه الى ان تعلن الولايات
المتحده بانها هي التي وراء هذا الاستهداف
لالقاف الايرانيه تفضل هل تعرفتم على
جنسيات القتل السبعه الذين سقطوا في التصف
يوم امس
بحسب مصادرنا في منطقه البوكمال الذين
يعملون داخل هذه الميليشياتهم من الاصدقاء
يعني بانهم من جنسيات غير سوريا عاملينها
مع داخل الاراضي السوريه قد يكون هنا
لبنانيين قد يقولون عراقيين او ايرانيين
لكن بشكل كلمه الاصدقاء لا تطلق على
السوريين العاملين مع ايران داخل التراب
السوريه
مباشره حدود السوريه العراقيه الاسبوع
الماضي همم هل يعني ذلك ان تم تتغارات همم
حدوديه وفي نظام المراقبه الذي تقف خلفه
جهاد الدوليه واقليميه همم تستغله ايران
بشكل قطع ايران ايران تستغل القضايا
الانسانيه قضيه دخول المساعدات الانسانيه
قضيه التجاره في سبيل ادخال السلاح يعني
ما جرى في يوم في الرابع والعشرين منها
الشهر الجاري عندما دخلت قافله البرادات
من العراق باتجاه الاراضي السوريه
من الاراضي السوريه ولم تفرق خضار حقيقه
الامريه ذهبت الى مطار عسكري حمولتها في
تلك المنطقه مراقبه بشكل طبيعي كبيره همم
تؤدي الى ادخال ايران السلاح الى داخل
التراب السوري وعندما قلت لك عندما يعبر
قياده في حزب الله لبنان كيف علم المرصد
بانه القياده في حزب الله اللبناني ولم
يعلم من هو على الحدود العراق
بان هذا الرجل يتنقل بالصوت والصوره عبر
الحدود وبرفقه عند السيارات من العراق
باتجاه الاراضي السوريه
اذا من القاهره كنت معنا مدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
شبه المستشار الالماني طريقه التعامل
النظام الايراني مع المحتاجين بحكم
الديكتاتوريه العسكريه في الارجنتين خلال
الفتره بين
1976 و
1983 التي راح ضحيتها ما يصل الى 30,000
شخص بعضهم قتل خلال الرحلات الجويه
المعروفه برحلات الموت حيث كان يتم اقائه
من الطائره شوز قال خلال زيارته لنصف بها
هؤلاء الضحايا في العاصمه الارجنتينيا انه
يجد نفسه مضطر لان يفكر بشكل مباشر في
الشباب الذين يتعرضون لقتل في ايران وهم
يكافحون من اجل حريتهم ومن اجل حياه افضل
[موسيقى]
روحي بقى معنا
القدس
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد قتلت القوات
الاسرائيليه الشاب نسيم ابو فوده في مدينه
الخليل بالقرب من حاجز 160 بجوار المسجد
الابراهيمي الجيش انه قتل الشعب بالخطا
بعد الاشتباه به وكانت العديد من المدن
والقرى الفلسطينيه قد شهدت مواجهات مع
القوات الاسرائيليه فيما واصل المستوطنون
عبر مهاجمه فلسطينيه
حيث اطلقت الشرطه الاسرائيليه وبلديه
القدس حمله لهدم 14 منزلا بشكل سريع باعزل
من وزير الامن القومي اثمار
هدمت الشرطه الاسرائيليه منزلا يعود
المقدسي محمد مطر ثم انتقلت الى مناطق
واحياء اخرى وجاءت الخطوه الاسرائيليه
احد قرارات اللي اتخابها المجلس الامني
والسياسي المصغر نصط على سحب حقوق التامين
الوطني وامتيازات اخرى من عائلات الداعمين
للعمليات الاخيره الى جانب سحب الجنسيه
اضافه الى التسريع في اجراءات اصدار رخصه
حمل السلاح للاسرائيليين
اطلق 100 مؤرخ اسرائيلي رساله ارساله تحذر
من حكومه بنيامين نتنياه حيث اكد ان حكم
نتنياهو يعد خطرا استراتيجيا على اسرائيل
وقال المؤرخون الذين يعملون في جامعاتنا
السائليه ان حكومه نتنياهو بوضعها خطه
لاضافيه في جهاز القضاء تشكل خطرا على
وجود دوله اسرائيل والامه الاسرائيليه على
حد وصفهم معتبرين ان هذه الخطه تهدد مواطن
اسرائيل الذين يخرجون للتظاهر كما تعد
تحديدا للاقتصاد الاسرائيلي ايضا
مشاهدينا من القدس العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا
بك زياد وهل توفرت المدينه المعروف
المعلومات حول ملابسات مقتل ابو فوده في
الخليل
عن مقتل الشاب الفلسطيني ابو فوده في
منطقه الخليل هل توفرت تلميذنا معلومات
حول ملابسات هذه العمليه
لا حاليا المعلومات
بالخطا من قبل هكذا اقر الجيش الاسرائيلي
على الاقل فتح النار عليه بالقرب من الحرم
الابراهيمي في مدينه الخليل في جنوب الضفه
الغربيه المحتله عمليه بهذا يصبح يعني
اسرائيل قتلت منذ بدايه هذا الشهر وحتى
الان ثلاثه 30
عمليا يرتقوا برصاص اسرائيلي في مختلف
المناطق نقصد الضفه الغربيه القدس كذلك
الامر بطبيعه الحال هذا فقط الان يزيد
للدرجات التوتر القائمه اصلا على الارض
بسبب ايضا الاجراءات واعتداءات المستوطنين
اليوميه على الكره الفلسطينيه هذه الليله
ايضا اجراء احراق سيارات وما الى ذلك
الاسرائيلي كما حدث مع ابو هدى بقتله
الفلسطينيا بالخطا هل يترتب على ذلك شيء
مثل همم
اجراءات عقابيه او قانونيه او حتى تعويضيه
لعائلته ما الذي يجري في العاده
في 99% من الحالات عمليا لا يحاسب الجنود
الاسرائيليون في اي من هذا الموضوع لانه
عمليا يقول شعرته بالخطر اطلقت النار
وينتهي الامر في التحقيق هكذا بالعاده
بمعنى القاعده عدم تقديم الجنود الى همم
المحاكمه او اتخاذ اجراءات عقبيه ورايين
فقط عندما ايضا في مدينه الخليل قبل سنتين
عندما قتل جندي اسرائيلي مصابا فلسطينيا
على الارض كان حيا همم تم تقديم تقديمه
للمحاكمه اسرائيل عمليا انقسمت بين مؤيد
للجندي وبين معارض في دلاله على ما اقول
بان يعني في الغالب لا تتخذ اي اجراء طيب
الينا وصلت عمليات تنفيذ الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه العقربيه الاخيره بحق
الفلسطينيين
طبعا بالامس كان هناك عمليه اغلاق بيت
منفذ عمليه المستوطنه التي قتل فيها سبعه
مستوطنين في القدس الشرقيه
وكذا ايضا اللافت كان قرار الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ايضا الشروع في اجراءات
لاغلاق منزل الطفل ابن الثالث عشر الذي
نفذ عمليه ولماذا اقول ان الامر لافتن
لانها العمليه لم تؤدي الى مقتل
اسرائيليين في العاده عمليه الاغلاق
تمهيدا للهدم تتم بعد عمليات التي يقتل
فيها اسرائيليون هذه المره همم وهذا طبعا
تغيير بسبب ضغط بين كبير في جلسه الحكومه
الامنيه المصغره تقرر ايضا اغلاق منزل
عائله هذا الطفل تمهيدا لهدمه ليس ذلك فقط
استغل الموضوع كما تقول مصادر في اسرائيل
واطلق حمله هدم عمليه في حي سلوان جنوب
القدس المحتله
10 مبنا عمليا مهدده بالهدف الاهلي
في بعضها من نتائج عكسيه لهذه الاجراءات
العقابيه بحق الفلسطينيين كزياده معدل
العمليات ضد الاسرائيليين
هذا صحيح وهذا ما يحذر منه ايضا حتى
النيون في اسرائيل بان هناك قاعده
فيزيائيه بسيطه بان الضغط يولد الانفجار
وبالتالي همم عمليا يعني ممارسه مثل هذه
الامور وهناك خشيه ايضا لدى الدوائر
الامينيه حتى في اسرائيل من انتقام
المستوطنين والمتطرفين اليهود لان هذا
الامر ايضا قد يشعل الميدان همم تماما
بدون ان نشاك بان الامور ذاهبه الى مزيد
من التصعيد ان كان لجهه العمليات الفرديه
الفلسطينيه المرشحه ان تستمر وان كان حول
عمليه انتقاميه من المستوطنين وعمليات
عسكريه للجيش الاسرائيلي واسعه النطاق
نسبيا في الضفه الغربيه
ايضا هذا يقرب حرب جديده على غزه هذه
القراءه الحاليا في اسرائيل مع وصوله
اليوم
يستاهل لوزير خارج الامريكي جولته الرابعه
للشرق الاوسط بزياره القاهره على واقعه
الصعيد الكبير لاعمال العنفي بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين ومن المقرر ان
يلتقي اليوم خلال زيارته الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي و نظيره المصري سامح شكري
لدفع الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين البردين
وتعزيز الامن والسلامه في المنطقه وكذلك
مناقشه اخر تطورات النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني قبل ان يتوجه الى القدس اورام
الله هذا هو قال وزير خارج امريكا في
مقابله مع عربيه حين واشنطن تؤيد اجراء
الانتخابات في ليبيا في هذه المرحله واكد
ان ليبيا تحتاج الى حكومه واضحه وشرعيات
تمثل الشعب الليبي وان الحفاظ على وحده
ليبيا لن يتم الا بالانتخابات التي تعبر
عن الشعب
ندعموا في هذه المرحله حاجه التوجه الى
الانتخابات في ليبيا وان تكون هناك حكومه
واضحه تدعم طموحات الشعب الليبيه وهذا ما
تحدث عنه مبعوث الى ليبيا وعلى الحكومه ان
تكون شرعيه وتلبي تطلعات الشعب
يقوم رئيس مجلس النواب صالح بزياره الى
القاهره هي الثانيه خلال الشهر الجاري هذا
ولم يعلق الناطق باسم المجلس عبد الله
مليحه بالتاكيد او النفي على احتمال
اجتماع صالح مع رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خالد المشري لبحث الملفات العالقه بشان
القاعده الدستوريه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه المؤجله هذا ولا جزائر
الخلافات الدائره حول القاعده الدستوريه
محل جدلا بين صالح والمشري اذا صرح صالح
سابقا انه يلتقي الاخير بالقاهره وذلك في
اطار حديثه علي المداولات الجاريه بين
المجلسين بشان هذه القاعده اللازمه لاجراء
الانتخابات
اظهرت الارقام الاوليه في تونس ان نسبه
المشاركه في جوله الاعاده من الانتخابات
البرلمانيه التي انعقدت امس الاحد بلغت
احد 10%
حسب المتحدث باسم هيئه الانتخابات وتعتبر
نسبه المشاركه متدنيه للغايه كما في
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات في ديسمبر
في الشوط الثاني من الاستحقاق التشريعيه
بنسبه مشاركه بلغت احدى عشر فاصل ثلاثه
بالمئه الى حدود الساعه السادسه
للعربيه الحدث عن اسباب تراجع نسب الاقبال
على التصويت اكد المسؤولون عن هيئه
الانتخابات انهم قاموا بكل ما يلزم لانجاح
الانتخابات مع ضروره البحث في الاسباب هذا
التراجع اكيد عنده اسبابه واسبابه
سياتي الوقت ربما للتقييم ويجب ان يكون
التقييم علمي وموضوعي
عمليه التصويت في مختلف الدوائر تمت بشكل
عادي اما من توجه الى مراكز الاقتراع
فقالوا انهم ينتظرون ان تعود ثقه ويتم
القطع مع المنظومه القديمه لابد من المذي
الى الامام هذه فرصه تاريخيه لن تتكرر
بفردي ارادته والقطع مع المنظومات القديمه
اللي حاشتنا بها تسترجع الثقه
تونس بالفم والاملاء على التونسي ان يبادر
على التونسي ان يقوم همم ما هو واجب عليك
لتتحسن الاوضاع
وينتظر ان تعلن النتائج الاوليه بدايه
الشهر القادم على ان تعلن النتائج
النهائيه في شهر مارس اصغر المقبل
وبعد حسن المصاري التشريعيه في انتظار
استكمال الطعون والاعلان عن النتائج
النهائيه تتوجه الانظار صوب تركيز
البرلمان الجديد بوصفه اخر محطه في المسار
الاصلاحيه والقطع مع المنظومه القديمه
وليد عبد الله العربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشف رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني سابق ويلسون في وثائقي
تبثه هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هدده باستهدافه
بالصاروخ قبل حرب اوكرانيا قائل له ان
الامر سيستغرق دقيقه واحده مضيفا تفاصيل
حول مكالمه له مع بوت وصفها بالطويره جدا
وغير العاديه واوضح خلال الوثائقي انه حذر
عقوبات القاسيه التي قد يتخذها غرب ضد
في اي وقت قريب وهو ما اثار السياقه طالب
منه مزيدا من التوضيح او ماذا يعني بمصطلح
اي وقت قريب الامر الذي ادى الى تهديد
الرئيس الروسي لبوليس جونسون رئيس الوزراء
انذاك حسب قوله
تواجه باريس تحديات الناحيه الى اعاده
نقودها في بلدان اخرى في منطقه الساحل في
الوقت ذاته يرى خبراء تنامي للنفود الروسي
في هذه البلدان في بينها دوله مالي
[تصفيق]
تسير بوركينا فاسو شيئا فشيئا يتراجع نفوذ
فرنسي في منطقه الساحل خروج
للنقود الروسي من الابواب نفسها ولكن
عمليه احلال وتبديل النفوذ جاءت على مراحل
وفقا للخبراء
نهايه مهمه فرنسا التي يبلغ قوامها نحو
400 جندي في بوركينا فاسو تاتي بعد 10
اشهر من طرد قواتها من مالي المجاوره
نهايه في مالي وبوركينا فاسو وبدايه في
النيجر المتخمه للبلدين
الوجود الروسي داخل الساحل وافريقيا لم
يتم بين ليله وضحاها يرى خبراء ان روسيا
قامت بحملات دعائيه للتاثير على السياسه
الافريقيه لصالح موسكو في المقابل تم حظر
الاذاعه الفرنسيه في بوركينا فاسو وفي
مالي هتف المئات امام السفاره الفرنسيه
رافعين الاعلام الروسيه
القياده العسكريه الجديده في كل من
بوركينا فاسو ومالي تريد حليفا جديدا نمت
العلاقات بين الكريم والقاده السياسيين في
منطقه الساحل حتى اصبحت روسيا الشركه
المحتمل في الحرب ضد الارهاب وتحقيق ما
اخفقت في فرنسا
تعزيز الوجود الروسي في منطقه الساحل
الافريقي لا يخلو من الانتقادات الغربيه
في الواجهه يرى الغرب ان وجودها اسهم في
انهيار بطيء لقوات حفظ السلام التابعه
للامم المتحده والموجوده في مالي انسحاب
لقوات المانيه وبريطانيه ودينيماركيه
وسويديه انتقادات لم تحرك ساكنا امام رياح
التوجه الجديد من منطقه الساحل فبعد عقود
من السيطره الفرنسيه وتراجع الشعبيتها تضع
روسيا موتها لاقدامها بين الشركائها في
افريقيا
على السمان العربيه
مشاهدينا كشفت تقرير وصحيفه اكبر مع احد
لابحاث الاسلحه النوويه في الصين اشترى
رقائق كمبيوتر امريكيه متطوره
10 مرات في العامين ونصف العام الماضي
تصدير الامريكيه التي استمرت لعقود واشار
التقير الى ان وثائق المشتريات تظهر ان
الاكاديميه الصينيه الفيزياء الهندسيه
التي تديرها الدوله تمكنت منذ عام 2020 من
الحصول على اشباه الموصلات التي تصنعها
شركات امريكيه على الرغم من وضعها على
قائمه سوداء امريكيه للتصدير في عام 1960
حرب جديده قد تستعرض بين الولايات المتحده
والصين تستخدم فيها اصغر الاسلحه في
العالم الرقائق الالكترونيه واشباه
الموصلات التي باتت جزءا اساسيا في
تكنولوجيا السلاح الجديد
لابحاث الاسلحه النوويه تبعا للحكومه
الصينيه اشترى رقاقات كمبيوتر متطوره من
الولايات المتحده بشكل غير مباشر اكثر من
اثنتين 10 مره خلال سنتين ونصف السنه
غير المباشر تجاوزت قيود تصدير الامريكيه
المفروضه منذ عقوده والتي تهدف الى منع
استخدام اي من منتجات الولايات المتحده
لابحاث الاسلحه الذريه من قبل قوى خارجيه
وهو ما يفعله مع هذا الابحاث الذي اشترى
رقائقك مكوناتنا لانظمه الحوسبه المخصصه
للاستهلاك الشخصي من بائعين في الصين
المعهد الذي يعرف باسم الاكاديميه الصينيه
للفيزياء الهندسيه من اوائل المؤسسات
الصينيه التي ادرجتها واشنطن على القائمه
السوداء بسبب ابحاثها النوويه واستخدامها
لاشباه الموصلات الامريكيه في تلك الابحاث
لتحليل البيانات وانشاء الخوارزميات
مخاوف وعبرت عنها وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
في نوفمبر الماضي قائله الى الصين تسرع
قدرتها النوويه
البنتاجون قدر ان الجيش الصيني سيخزن
حوالي 1000 و500 راس نووي بحلول 2035
بينما العدد الحالي هو 400
وتكون المشكله في السيطره على امتلاك تلك
الرقائق في انه يتم تصنيعها خارج الولايات
المتحده ما يصعب مهمه مراقبه الصادرات
ووجهتها النهائيه
تفاضل المركز الصيني لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها بان الموته الحاليه من
الاصابات بفيروس كورونا في الصين تتجه نحو
الانخفاض واضاف المركز ان الاصابات لن
تشهد ارتفاعا كبيرا خلال عطله راس السنه
القمريه الجديده
التراجع عن خطه رفع سن التقاعد مع استعداد
النقابات لجوله احتجاجات واضرابات جديده
يوم غدا الثلاثاء وجدت رئيسه الحكومه على
ان رفع الحد الادنى لسن التقاعد من 62
عاما الى 64 والذي اخترعها الرئيس الفرنسي
من ضمن حزمه من الاصلاحات غير مقابل
ثمان نقابات في فرنسا وفي توافق نادي
بينها ووصفت الاصلاح بانه غير عادل وقالت
انها تامر في ان تتجاوز احتجاجات الثلاثاء
القادم الاحتجاجات التي نظمت في التاسعه
عشر من يناير وان تكون اكبر تعبئه
ولا مشاهدينا بقيه ان نذكره بالعناوين
معارك طاحنه
في ضواحي المدينه يخلف قتلى وجرحى
المرصد يؤكد سقوط سبعه
ايرانيه بمدينه القائم الحدوديه
ايران تهدد اوكرانيه وتطالبها بتبرئه
نفسها من هجمات اصفهان والبنتاجونيين
تقارير تؤكد حصول الصين على رقائق امريكيه
لمعهد ابحاث اسلحه نوويه رغم قيود التصدير